[Music]
on this Wednesday night an entire city
going under quarantine the center of
China's corona virus outbreak to be
closed off to public transportation it's
a big challenge the Chinese authorities
more deaths more patients and the
lessons learned from Canada's experience
with SARS deadly vacation in Quebec as
snowmobiling ride turns tragic for a
group of tourists and was the world's
richest man hacked
I think absurd is exactly the right word
the suspicions Saudi Arabia targeted
Amazon's CEO plus humor and heartwarming
gestures born in a blizzard
[Music]
global national with Donna Frieza
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with drastic measures
being taken to try to contain the
outbreak of a mysterious pneumonia like
virus Chinese authorities are
effectively putting a quarantine on an
entire city cutting off Wuhan where the
potentially deadly coronavirus first
emerged in December planes trains buses
Subway's and ferries to and from that
city of 11 million will be suspended
tomorrow the aim is to cut off
transmission of the virus but it is
spreading at least 17 people have died
more than 500 others are infected there
are now confirmed cases in South Korea
Taiwan Thailand Japan and the u.s. there
are no confirmed cases here in Canada
though tonight five people in Quebec who
recently returned from China are being
monitored the World Health Organization
has teams on the ground in China and is
holding off on declaring a global health
emergency for now it's advising
governments to be vigilant and ready to
test
anyone who has traveled to the affected
region and has symptoms like cough and
fever
Christel go man singh has our top story
tonight they have no option but to get
up close and care for those who are ill
the new strain of the corona virus is
spreading fast in China and beyond
Chinese officials in Wuhan have made
masks mandatory and are implementing
drastic measures to limit people's
movements taking the action that they
think is appropriate it's very important
we stress to them that by having a
strong action not only they will control
their out the outbreak in their country
but they all they will also minimize the
chances of this outbreak spreading
internationally in Wuhan where the virus
first appeared in December hospitals are
overrun with people with flu-like
symptoms but in some cases it can be
much more serious this new virus is in
the same family as the common cold it's
triggering fear because it's also the
same chain as SARS Europe's busiest
airport Heathrow will be screening for
signs of illness on planes and asking
more questions
people when they land we're also asking
them to self declare and in other words
if they have any signs of symptoms to
let us know so that that can be assessed
and any appropriate assess further
assessment in just a few days the virus
has led to hundreds of confirmed cases
and more than a dozen deaths containing
the virus is critical
Wu hen is a large center and a
commercial hub UK officials anticipate
the infection rate will reach into the
thousands it is Michael clearly that we
understand the right of human-to-human
transmission that will determine the
frankly how the feasibility of control
and if the control is feasible what
measures will be needed there is no
vaccine the virus is new so no one knows
exactly what it can do and there's
always potential for it to mutate
officials with the World Health
Organization will meet again Thursday as
it continues to monitor the virus
crystal commencing Global News London
trying to contain an outbreak of an
infectious virus while not completely
shutting down trade and travel is a
balancing act
Canada's experience during the SARS
outbreak in 2003 when 44 Canadians died
Todd authorities many lessons tonight
Eric Sorenson takes a closer look at the
new corona virus and how ready Canada is
for it in Shanghai they quickly sold out
of face masks as viruses go it's still
not clear how transmissible and how
severe the novel coronavirus is how
efficient is human to human transmission
because really that's going to be one of
the driving forces behind whether or not
this turns into something a little bit
larger or whether or not we're able to
get this under control a little bit
quicker
there are many corona viruses from the
new novel coronavirus to severe cases
like SARS to the common cold corona
viruses are commonplace among animals
it's when they spread animals to humans
than from human to human
the risks increase the novel coronavirus
was first found in Wuhan China and has
spread to nearby countries and to the
United States there's so much travel
from
chyna to the rest of the world a further
spread is entirely realistic compared
with SARS it also began in China in 2003
there were more than 8,000 cases 90%
were in China Hong Kong and Taiwan but
SARS spread to more than 30 countries
and outside Southeast Asia Canada was as
hard-hit as any other country an
estimated 250 cases and 44 deaths it's
been 18 years since and this is looking
as many similarities to cells in terms
of you know big an outbreak in China
with lots of people hospitalized and in
some indications of industrial spread is
it of international concern
definitely Toronto in particular was
hard hit by SARS and the global reaction
to it the World Health Organization told
travelers to avoid coming here pamphlets
were distributed at the airport health
care workers were forced to wear more
protection hospitals restricted visitors
thousands of people were quarantined
hand sanitizing became a widespread
practice in 2003 Canada seems much
better prepared now certainly there's
education and screening at ports of
entry for this we now have tests and
instructions to healthcare providers on
how to manage cases as bad as SARS was
the hospital's here are certainly
well-prepared now from after that
experience to deal with imported
infectious diseases the global response
to the new corona virus has been much
quicker than it was for SARS thanks in
part to China's transparency and
reporting it early still the number of
international cases is bound to rise and
just one case in Canada could create a
national sense of urgency given this
country's experience with SARS Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto the airport
in st. John's Newfoundland has finally
reopened to commercial flights after the
massive blizzard there yes six days
later I got a flight home flights
resumed at 5 a.m. bringing relief to
those who have been stranded since the
storm hit on Friday about 400 flights to
and from st. John's were canceled when
the airport was snowed in and shut down
Air Canada and West jet are adding some
flights in the next couple of days to
get the backlog of passengers on their
way the cleanup from that monster
snowstorm is going to take a while the
Canadian military says 400 troops on the
ground will
as long as needed they're helping dig
out the homes of elderly and vulnerable
people a state of emergency that remains
in effect in st. John's so crews can
safely clear all that snow from the
streets the city expects to lift all
restrictions by 6 a.m. Saturday that
means most businesses are still closed
there are driving restrictions until
then though taxis and heating oil trucks
are now being allowed on the roads
essential services like medical clinics
and some food banks have also been
allowed to reopen in Quebec a snowmobile
trip for a group of French tourists has
ended tragically five are missing and
their tour guide from Montreal is dead
after their snowmobiles plunged through
the ice on a river it happened near the
mouth of a river on the eastern side of
Lac saint-jean
north of the city of Elma that's about
200 kilometers north of Quebec City
every winter about thirty thousand
tourists many of them from France go to
Quebec to snowmobile Mike Armstrong
explains what we know about how this
trip went badly wrong
two police helicopters spent most of the
day in the air searching while below
divers were in the water one of the
helicopters actually crashed during the
search the pilot was alone he's injured
but his life is not in danger
let's give akattak seemeth police say
officers are still holding out hope
checking local cottages and cabins in
case the snowmobilers found refuge but
the odds are slim the group rented their
machines and see Michaud they say about
270 kilometers away they were eight
tourists from France and a guide
traveling along provincial trails well
it appears Tuesday night they left the
trails there speculation the guide may
have been taking a shortcut and they
ended up on the ice Joe it's davao so a
lot more than a local say everyone knows
not to go on the ice in that area the
current is too strong and the ice
doesn't always freeze thick enough ron
no homo well seven members of the group
fell through one got out right away he
and the other two tourists went to a
convenience store for help their
machines were still there this afternoon
a department by NICUs maman a clerk at
the store says the snowmobilers were
calling their friends trying to see if
they were okay they weren't panicking
because they didn't know they were in
the water well four hours later police
found the 40
two year old guide he was alive but died
in hospital the five others may have
been carried away by the current state
that keep what government says there
will be an investigation and that the
province was already looking at new
training and qualification programs for
guides provincial snowmobiling
Association says this event shows their
activity can be dangerous and people
should stick to trails this week is also
International snowmobile Safety Week
Mike Armstrong global news Montreal a
former Canadian Army reservists from
Manitoba linked to a violent white
supremacist group has been denied bail
in a US Court
a federal judge called Patrick Matthews
a very dangerous person who espouses
very dangerous beliefs Matthews was
arrested last week by the FBI along with
two other alleged members of a far-right
group called the base the FBI had been
watching them and searched their
Delaware apartment among the things they
found were videos Matthews recorded
wearing a gas mask espousing racist and
anti-semitic rhetoric calling for
violent revolution a motion filed in
court also alleges he discussed
ambushing civilians and police at a gun
rights rally in Virginia this week
Matthews is charged with several
firearms offenses and if convicted he
faces up to 20 years in prison just in
breaking political news here at home
rana ambrose former MP and interim
leader of the federal conservative party
has decided not to seek the leadership i
have really struggled with the decision
to return to political life I loved my
13 years in public service as an MP a
minister and especially as leader of
this great party but right now I'm
focused on making a difference through
the private sector creating policy and
advocating for our energy sector to
create jobs in that video Ambrose says
she also wants to continue her work to
ensure Canadian judges have sexual
assault law training the Conservative
Party is due to select a new leader in
June in Washington those involved in the
impeachment trial of President Donald
Trump got into heated arguments over
what shape that trial should take at the
heart of it are allegations Trump
pressured Ukraine to investigate his
political rival tonight the president is
thousands of kilometres away in Davos
Switzerland and he seemed to brag about
his
ability to obstruct the work of Congress
during the trial our Washington bureau
chief Jackson prosecco joins me Jackson
walk set walk us through what the
president said and why it matters well
Donna Trump was asked this morning if he
had committed an impeachable offense he
responded by suggesting Congress doesn't
have the full story because he won't
share key information with lawmakers
we're doing very well I got to watch
enough
I thought our team did a very good job
but honestly we have all the material
they don't have the material so the
president is essentially boasting about
the fact that the White House has not
turned over documents or produced
witnesses
remember they largely refuse to
cooperate with the House impeachment
inquiry and the Senate was up late last
night until nearly 2:00 in the morning
where Republicans blocked any measures
to subpoena documents or witnesses at
least for now what this means is that
for the next six days we're going to
hear essentially a rehash of the
evidence and arguments that we've
already heard and in the unlikely event
that Republicans do vote to allow
witnesses at some point later in the
trial Trump is already threatening that
he'll claim executive privilege to block
them
Donna Jo Jackson some moderate
Republicans have said they'd be open to
calling witnesses is there any reason to
think that they might well it would take
four of them but there's not a lot of
reason to think that's going to happen
at least not right now some Republicans
in fact are already laying the
groundwork to say there's no need to
hear from witnesses because we already
know the arguments that both sides are
going to make over the next six days I
think the record is pretty complete I'm
opposed to having any more witnesses
because you don't need them and that's
if you have one or two or three
witnesses then they're gonna ask for
more because it's a stalling technique
so Donna all of this is to say that as
of right now there's no reason to expect
that there's going to be anything to
steer Republicans off-course from their
plans to acquit President Trump and move
on from impeachment as quickly as
possible okay Jackson Prosecco in
Washington Thanks
Saudi Arabia's staunch denials coming up
why it's accused of hacking the phone
belonging to Amazon's CEO
there are reports the world's richest
man Jeff Bezos had his phone hacked by
the crown prince of Saudi Arabia Bezos
owns Amazon and the Washington Post
that's the paper that employed murdered
journalist Jamal khashoggi to UN Human
Rights experts want a full investigation
saying it appears to be an attempt to
influence if not silence reporting on
Saudi Arabia The Guardian newspaper
reports Bezos had his mobile phone
hacked in 2018 through a whatsapp
message reportedly sent by the personal
account of the Saudi Crown Prince it's
alleged the encrypted video contained
malware that enabled surveillance of
bezos's phone I think absurd is exactly
the right word the idea that the comp
Prince would hack Jeff Bezos his phone
is absolutely silly in 2018 Saudi Arabia
had been critical of the Washington Post
coverage including columnist Jamal
khashoggi who was an outspoken critic of
the regime
he was then tortured killed and
dismembered inside Saudi Arabia's
consulate in Istanbul Turkey today Bezos
said nothing but he did tweet this photo
with the hashtag Jamal it was taken at a
vigil in 2019 commemorating the one-year
anniversary of Khashoggi murder Terry
Jones co-founder and co-star of the
Monty Python comedy troupe has passed
away at the age of 77 four years ago
he'd been diagnosed with a rare form of
dementia
[Applause]
anyone who knows it knows that's from
life of brine which Jones directed one
of his countless achievements he was
both a star on-screen and a genius
behind the scenes fellow pythons sir
Michael Palin said today he was far more
than one of the funniest writer
performers of his generation he was the
complete Renaissance comedian writer
director presenter historian brilliant
children's author and the warmest most
wonderful company you could wish to have
we're back in a moment always look on
the bright side of life
always look on the light side apply
there's a massive resource project being
planned in this country and if built it
would be one of the largest oil sands
mines ever built in Alberta the tech
frontier mined 25 kilometers south of
Wood Buffalo National Park would cover
24 thousand hectares that's about twice
the size of Vancouver at its peak it
would produce 260 thousand barrels of
bitumen everyday that would take up
about half the capacity that will be
available when the trans mountain
pipeline expansion is built the tech
frontier mine would generate 4 million
tons of greenhouse gas emissions every
year the final decision on approval is
now in the hands of Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau's cabinet tonight Heather
Eurex West looks at the difficult
balancing act on the streets of Calgary
with construction of the trans Mountain
High pine now underway focus has shifted
to a new oil and gas project last month
when Alberta's premier sat down with the
prime minister in Ottawa the proposed
tech frontier oil sands mega project was
among the first topics discussed that
would create 10,000 jobs 70 billion
dollars in revenue for governments to
pay for health care and education
proposal comes at a difficult time for
the industry investor confidence in
Canada's energy sector is low this
analyst believes anything but an
approval could kill any future
investments I could see this problem
quit problems going ballistic and I
think that's going to be a real a real
stab in the heart of the primes Alberta
and Ottawa have agreed on an overall
emissions cap for the oil sands and this
project would not exceed that limit but
it would mean overall carbon emissions
would increase it's why
environmentalists are calling on Ottawa
to reject tech enlisting some star power
in recent weeks from celebrities like
Joaquin Phoenix Jane Fonda and Martin
Sheen well there is some opposition to
this mega project there is also support
and the company has signed agreements
with 14 indigenous communities in the
region do I believe and do I agree with
with the fact that there can be major
impacts absolutely that's what
mitigation is for and that's what that's
we did the work for over two years to be
able to ensure that we are mitigating
everything we possibly can on the
project the fort Makai matey president
is urging Ottawa to approve the mine in
an exclusive interview with Global News
earlier this month the Prime Minister
said the decision is being weighed
carefully we are going through that
processes right now and that process
will result in a decision but I'm not
going to prejudge with that decision but
the choice must be made soon under
Canada's environmental assessment act
cabinet's decision is due by the end of
February Heather your ex west global
news Calgary next cold days warm hearts
in Newfoundland and Labrador
the wild winter weather that battered
Newfoundland set a lot of people back
but couldn't cool the spirit of the
place the way Newfoundlanders pulled
together after the storm and took their
troubles in stride is no surprise to
those who know and love the province and
as Ross Lord reports it's a lesson all
of us can learn from in a province we're
leaning on each other comes naturally
they fight a record-setting blizzard
with historic generosity people have
been shut in for a few days and are
probably pretty hungry so we're hoping
to put out 60 to 100 meals today so so
people can withstand this state of
emergency a little bit longer most
restaurants are shut down
but Stella's circle charity got special
permission to make special meals that
it's cafe for the homeless and others
who are unable to go out and feed
themselves as they discard the mountains
of snow Newfoundlanders treasure the
things worth keeping
including moments of levity in the car
laughter a tried-and-true method of
countering adversity along with the
soothing power of song I want to break
free
housebound for days on end by
claustrophobia inducing snowbanks good
material for a tune I don't want to see
the snow on top of the countless number
of volunteers shoveling out their
neighbors taxi companies are providing
free rides to seniors and people with
disabilities congested mostly a lot of
the streets were just one-way streets
but other than that everybody was
patient and given everybody a break
some people are extra grateful
Christopher Rose is making meal
deliveries for Stella's circle
participants including himself but get
one of myself which is very very very
thankful for of they're getting some
actual nutritious meal to beat storm
chips for once enduring the extremes of
bad weather by using their own good
nature
raus lord global news and that is global
national for this wednesday i'm dona
freezin tonight's your canada is these
two brothers Asher and Kyler peddling
their homemade Zamboni around their
backyard rink in Vernon BC could have
used them in Newfoundland thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
bye bye
[Music]